- Une table ronde pour des pays
virtuel qui réclame à nouveau
un soutien accru pser
l'envahisseur russe.
Un système de défense aérien
moderne et des sanctions pluss ,
le président Zelensky souhaite
que la guerre soit terminée
d'ici l'hiver.ders du G7 prennee
des demandes de l'Ukraine et
relèvent leurs manches pour en
arriver à une stratégie commune.
Le président Biden promet des
canons antiaériens; le Canada,
de nouvelles sanctions dans
le secte Et depu Et depu Et dep,
le secrétaire général de l'OTAN
renchérit; il souhaite tripler
le nombre de soldats de sa force
d'interv
"Loin des horreurs de
est parfois difficile", avoue
Justin Trudeau.
Le chancelier allemand prévient
qu'il faune escalade
entre l'OTAN et la Russie.
Les dirigeants au châteauvantvt
un horizon incertain.
lance donc une opération
charme. Cinq pays en voie de
développ
en Bavière, des pays qui
hésitentcer publiquement
la Russie. En les aidant
à surmo
causée par la guerre, le G7
les inciter à tourner
le dos à la Russie dans une
Vladimir Poutine.
EMMANUELEMMANUELEMMANUELEMMANUE,
président de la France
d'aider, dans ce contexte-làaust
les pays émergents.
premier ministre du Canada
- C'est des moments importants
pour des leaders progressistes
justement de conti... avoir un t
positif dans un monde qui est
de plus en plus troublé.
- Prochaine étape demain,
au sommeLes Premiers ministres ,
de l'Australie et de la Corée
du Sud seront invités pour
la première fois. Devant
l'agressivité de lne,
les pays membres de l'OTAN se
cherchenaux alliésaux alliésaux.
Ici Christian Noël,
Radio Canada à Garmisch-